hey guys this is
tommy with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and we're in alaska
[Music]
well it's 6 30 in the morning and i just
woke up my brother and we're going
salmon fishing
well if looks could catch us fish this
spot would do it looks good
probably something right about here
see what
happens oh you said that man said that
there's something down there yeah i
think a smaller hook is going to do you
better yeah i got a number 12 right
there is
i don't get much smaller than that oh
there you go
my trout rod hooked me a silver here
holy mackerel
a little smaller yeah beautiful though
there's a
beautiful trout
oh no no no we got a sucker
[Music]
there we go
long nose sucker that man that looks a
lot like a nigoy in japan
oh nice little rainbow
nice rainbow
that beautiful little rainbow
there you go ransom congratulations pick
him up tom
i have a job no hey reel him in tom oh
once you reel it and see what happens
[Music]
no
he got away sorry buddy
well that's not bad i think we've caught
five or six rainbows a dollyvarden a
sucker and a silver i count that as
catching it because i touched it
so it was on the bank it was on the bank
and i touched it so that's catch and
release
hold up pull up his fish is on
little muddy dolly
are you stuck in the mud oh he got out
oh
come up and reel it he's already on
there
it's fighting yes it's a nice rainbow
[Applause]
not a bad rainbow look at the colors on
him
gorgeous
all right there you go
there we go
oh i got another rainbow there
another nice little rainbow
boys what are you doing
don't throw mine at me
[Music]
oh there's that there's that sucker
again
long nose sucker right there yeah it's
like right here
that's lower
there you go
you're getting your alaska grown shirt
dirty uh oh nathan's got himself stuck
nathan
are you stuck
all right let me get you out
wiggle your feet
[Music]
nathan you're muddy
but your skin looks so youthful
[Music]
is that better
i love you buddy
keep your arm tip up
well guys we caught about 15 to 20
rainbow trout
two or three dollyvarden we caught three
whitefish and a silver so not bad for
about two or three hours but tommy here
is very wet and are you cold bud
yeah
and uh nathan too is a little bit
cold and dirty so
we're gonna call it a day get him back
to the cabin warm them up
[Music]
you want me to wash your feet off tommy
you feeling better
nathan you feeling better buddy
you've got a dirty ear there
yeah we gotta clean your ear out all
right we're gonna go back to the river
and see how my brother's doing
wow it was it was it got off the hook oh
it's so bad i was like get it were you
pinning that thing yeah he wants he
wants to keep it
all right man good job you taking those
home to eat yes
awesome how many did you end up catching
um
i think like five or six but a lot of
them uh we let go
man just crushed it with the rainbows
today yeah
here you want a stringer sure i guess
the hill
because there's so many rods
all right
all right well we're getting the cabin
straightened up we're gonna get out of
here go to get some food you boys hungry
yeah
all right let's go get some serious
breakfast come here and
grab daddy
you're right you'll get buckled up in
your car seat
all right guys we're going to talking to
you guys want uh breakfast do you want
pizza pizza
[Music]
we're here at mountain high pizza pie in
talkeet now we're gonna grab some food
for the road here all right we ordered
two extra large pizzas the carnivore and
the five cheese so we're gonna see how
that goes are you ready
let's go
so my brother's carrying tommy out to
the restroom and tommy yells hurry up i
might pee on your back
classy
nathan
nathan you've been picking your face
again
oh we're taking family photos in an hour
mom's gonna kill you
and maybe me too all right let's go home
and we're gonna get
washed and bathed
and we're gonna get to hug and kiss
mommy
so we've got all of our family here in
alaska so of course we're doing a big
family picture so we're getting all
gussied up
got the sand out of my boy's ears and uh
we're gonna
do everything to make mommy happy family
picture time
i've gotta put away the camera so we can
pull out another camera and do family
pictures
well good morning everybody this is our
last day in alaska and i'm kind of sad
because
i thought we had pretty much a full day
tomorrow and we're leaving tomorrow
night we're leaving tomorrow morning so
yeah that's happening and we wanted to
do a big hike uh today and go hike up a
gold mine up in hatcher's pass but in
the meantime before we do that i need to
fuel up so we are going to go
get breakfast
and i'm going to go to the south side
grill all right here we are
there we go we got food for everybody
have a good time those waitresses are so
nice to nathan
jacob it looks like you just ate all
right there we go reindeer sausage eggs
pancakes breakfast of alaskan champions
all right guys you ready to go up hiking
with cousins
[Music]
so
okay we're here at hatcher's past alaska
near the independence gold mine now the
independence gold mine is a fascinating
abandoned gold mine
when the price of gold dropped in like
the 50s
they thought it was going to open up
anytime soon again you know it was just
a temporary shutdown so they left
everything inside
and walked away from it but then a few
days turned a few months to a few years
and it's an abandoned goldmine never
opened back up
my dad's uncle was actually the
caretaker the gold mine when my dad was
a little boy and he used to come up here
and get to play and and go inside the
gold mine and the old office houses and
everything but then it got sold to the
state park service and now it's a park
and anybody can go here but we're here
with almost the entire family and uh my
mom and my
wife are gonna paint
and uh we're gonna go hike up to a
little lake and uh who knows might be
able to find some fishing i have no idea
if there's any fish in here we're we're
pretty high up in the elevation there
may not be anything in there but it's a
beautiful area so
it'll be fun hey jacob you having fun
yeah you're liking grandma
come on nathan you got to walk
this is pretty cool huh this is gorgeous
[Music]
we used to come up here as boy scouts
and
we would uh camp and make snow caves in
the wintertime
and then the daytime we take our sleds
and
climb up the side of the mountain and
sled down
[Music]
you can catch dad
look at that old cabin
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm doing good
[Applause]
[Music]
well guys i don't see any fish here i
see a few water bugs on top
but that's it i mean it is crystal
crystal clear it gets really deep right
there but i don't see any fish
oh no not the butt crack oh
i swedgey
nathan
nathan buddy that's really cold water
i don't have any snow
yourself tommy
well the boys jumped in the water got
themselves muddy and wet as they always
do but
man check out this view
that's pretty cool
good view of the mine over there
well i'm disappointed there was no fish
in there i was hoping that maybe there'd
be some golden fin or something in there
but
hey it was still pretty and we had fun
and
gotta throw snowballs in july so that's
cool
[Music]
there we go we did it
hiked all the way up there and back if
you want to do this hike it's gold cord
lake trail it's uh
about a mile each way i think
nathan you look a little wet and dirty
you tired and cold
let's go get you warmed up
[Music]
how you doing there's a smile for daddy
hey joe
[Music]
hello
when i was a little kid we used to camp
up here and i remember we snuck into
those buildings they weren't collapsed
back then
stuck our heads in there was old
crampons and mining equipment and
stuff up in there
the old quarters for the miners back in
the days yeah the old washroom
[Music]
just cardboard
check out these old slate top pool
tables
that's a big old engine
look at these little buildings
tom do you want me to leave behind you
let's see if i can show you the high
chair come on we're going up there
[Music]
hey
a lot of the metal all that had to be
shipped up from the lower 48s i mean
this was not a little task getting all
this stuff up here
it's just laying abandoned
whoa it's freezing
yeah it's cold in here isn't it
yeah there's the door to the mine it's
all gated up
yeah
yeah are you disappointed we couldn't go
down in the mine
this is the drills they used to to drill
the rocks and break up the rocks
grandma have you been babysitting jacob
yeah look at this play pit back here
this is perfect you're a sports utility
baby and he knows it hey nathan he
played his diaper
hey jacob did you miss me
all right boys come on let's go in the
car
so many happy memories growing up here
but uh tomorrow morning we're getting on
a plane
heading to british columbia all right
guys did you have fun
well it's our last night here in alaska
and we're back in anchorage so i am
taking my family my mom and my one of my
younger sisters
out to dinner but we gotta get some
clothes on nathan
he's naked all right you ready to go
have some dinner
yeah
go get it melanie
well guys we're leaving alaska tomorrow
morning our flight leaves at like 10 30
in the morning so
uh we're pretty much going to get up eat
breakfast go to the airport and uh
it's our last opportunity to have access
to a washer and dryer so we're doing
all of our laundry
and
taking care of all the boys stuff and
we've got look at all this packing we've
gotta do so
yeah i'm gonna stay up late tonight
packing everything getting everything
clean and ready to go and tomorrow we're
off to washington state and then british
columbia
thanks for watching we hope you enjoyed
this video check out this sneak peek of
the next installment of the 2018 world
tour if you like this video log series
don't forget to click the playlist link
in the video description below thanks
for watching if you want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning